so you want to go to Stanford yes
I almost got a perfect score on my SATs
you're a good student but Sierra
what's your step excuse me Sierra
Burgess is funny kid wonder
you are a magnificent beast I feel
sometimes I give the one teenager who
don't obsess over looks I'm sorry
I wonder what life is like rejects
Veronica photo is from Lord of the Rings
you're thinking of Quasimodo The
Hunchback of Notre Dom and meant looking
at you makes me want to gouge my eyes
out how many guy we texted he definitely
thinks that I'm someone else
let's call catfishing and I'm pretty
sure it's illegal oh my god Oh Veronica
Veronica that's what I have to live up
to all the phone numbers in the world he
texted mine you need to tell him the
truth
they're my words he's falling for me
any more than just a hot job are you
thinking wow no would you want to go on
a date with me oh yeah I know you've
been feeling all your classes so so I
think we can help each other but I do
need a favorite you sure this is gonna
work
no oh my gosh good answer Hey so how was
your day
you know what the audios not seen to the
video like at all maybe we should try
again another time could like me you are
exactly my type
any idea to be a teenage girl until
luckily you know the artist parts
allowing yourself to people
[Music]
oh the truth he's not ready
even though you are me more
wait your voice she's actually kind of
cool going that's terrifying
I know what I am
[Music]
you
you